hi mystery recapped here today I'm going
to explain a badass anime
adaptation called Full Metal Alchemist
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
[Music]
the movie is based in a fictional town
of resemble where people practice a rare
form of art known as Alchemy using this
art one can mold common metals like iron
and Cobalt into precious ones like gold
there are also people who use this art
for transmutation that is to resurrect
dead humans however it is not safe at
all rumors say that if the procedure
goes south there are grave consequences
I heard one guy even lost his dick one
time in the first scene we were
introduced to the Ulrich Brothers Edward
and Alphonse who have been self-learning
Alchemy from a young age they mostly use
books from their library to carry out
their experiments one day they prepare a
toy and happily show it to their mother
who congratulates them with a warm hug
however after they leave to play She
unexpectedly passes away due to a
cardiac arrest the boys now have no one
to look after them and their days start
turning into desperation so not willing
to give up on their mother Edward comes
up with an idea he mentions that using
the Alchemy book they can practice trans
mutation on their deceased mother and
bring her back Alphonse who has heard
rumors about the scary consequences
thinks that it is a bad idea but when
Edward reassures him that there is
nothing to worry about he agrees to help
in the next scene the two brothers start
their preparations they gather all the
ingredients as per the book and place
them at the center of the transmutation
circle as soon as they begin chanting
the ritual a dangerously large amount of
energy starts forming around the house
which eventually turns into a vortex at
this point the brothers finally realized
that their experiments has gone awry but
it is too late the vortex ultimately
rips their house off and destroys
everything in sight even their dicks
maybe the movie then fast forwards by 20
years and all grown-up Edward is chasing
after a priest with a mysterious red
stone it is revealed that the magical
rock is capable of Performing Alchemy
without the help of any ingredients
hence when the priest is cornered he
uses the stone to unleash Stone pillars
forcing Edward to retreat following this
he summoned several terrifying monsters
from the underworld and Edward also
conjures up his magic spear revealing
that he has become a master Alchemist
right then a giant armored figure
appears and starts beating up the
monsters one by one he uses his immense
strength and throws them around like
ragdolls but in the process his helmet
gets knocked off surprisingly the
armorer has no head and his body is
completely Hollow from the inside
meanwhile Edward finishes off the rest
of the monsters and reveals that he too
has prosthetic limbs he then mentions
that because of this trait in his body
everyone calls him the Full Metal
Alchemist the terrified priest tries
running away from there but Edward
eventually catches up to him he then
strikes the priest with his prosthetic
arm causing the latter's red stone to
get knocked off just when it appears as
if he has completed his mission the
military led by Colonel Mustang arrives
and apprehends both of them Edward begs
for the rock which he calls the
Philosopher's Stone but Colonel Mustang
quickly showcases that it is a fake this
devastates Edward as he has been looking
for the real one for years meanwhile the
armor also arrives and reveals that he
is none other than Edward's younger
brother Alphonse he did lose his dick he
tries to comfort Edward but due to the
distraction the priest manages to get
away later everyone heads to the
military base where Colonel Mustang
argues that there is no such thing as a
philosopher's stone you gotta stop
talking about that Harry Potter the
one that they encountered earlier was
simply an amplifier which has no
transmutation abilities at all however
Edward is still hopeful that the real
stone is out there somewhere he is
desperately looking for it so that he
can regenerate his brother and also his
lost limbs after the meeting as Edward
is preparing to head home he meets his
childhood best friend winry she mentions
that she learned about him through the
news and now wants to help him in his
mission of finding the Philosopher's
Stone elsewhere the priest reaches a
dark room where a trio of magical
gangsters are waiting for them led by
the Ferocious leader lost the group has
two other members Envy a tall being who
can transform into anyone and gluttony a
fat human who has the ability to devour
anything it turns out that the priest
was sent on an errand but since he
couldn't get the job done lust is
furious hence as a punishment she
extends her claws and impales him
brutally once the priest is dead
gluttony swoops in and eats him
meanwhile Edward is trying to get some
sleep but he keeps on having visions
about the incident from 20 years ago
right after the failed transmutation
process Edward is brought to the gate of
Truth where all knowledge of the
universe lies within then the gate
suddenly opens and he is sucked Inside
by some creepy tentacles oh Japan Edward
is sent flying through the universe and
at one point he sees his mother in the
distance he desperately tries to reach
out to her but the next second he is
again brought outside the gate however
now Edward has vast knowledge of alchemy
and how to use it without the books
right then a transparent deity appears
and introduces himself as God oh he says
that if anyone wants to bring their
loved ones back from the dead they will
have to make a deal saying this he takes
one of Edward's limbs away as the latter
had tried to bring his mother back later
Edward wakes up in his house which is
revealed to be still intact however his
limb is missing and even his brother
Alphonse is nowhere to be found this
makes him realize that even Alphonse
sacrificed himself for the Alchemy
Edward then tries to go near the place
where they had conducted the experiment
and notices a monstrosity of a human
which resembles nothing close to their
mother enraged he knocks over an armor
set and starts transmuting to bring his
brother back the plan works and he is
again brought outside the Gate of Truth
where the deity is waiting for him
however since he is requested for his
brother's life he has to again sacrifice
one of his limbs following this he wakes
up in his bed with two of his limbs
missing his brother alfonse has also
been brought back to life but only in
the form of armor back in the present
Colonel Mustang takes the brothers and
Winery to an ex experienced Alchemist
named Tucker hoping that he has some
information on the Philosopher's Stone
once they arrive at his Mansion talker
shows them his inventions he has created
some hybrid organisms by fusing
different animals with one another he
then reveals that some years ago he was
a prominent State Alchemist working for
the government but unfortunately all his
experiments were deemed useless and so
he was kicked out now he is trying his
best to come up with different
inventions so that he can be reinstated
back to his position somehow I don't
think inventing cat dog is going to do
that for him in the next scene Tucker
and Edward have a private meeting where
the latter Reveals His entire story and
why he is after the precious stone
Tucker mentions that while he doesn't
know its exact location he will
definitely help in retrieving it
following this Edward and winry board a
train to another city they are
attempting to meet Dr Marco another
scientist who apparently knows about the
Philosopher's Stone unfortunately their
first meeting is very hostile as Marco
mistakes them for bad guys and points a
gun at them in response once Edward
tries to calm him down but ends up
knocking him out when Marco regains
Consciousness he refuses to talk about
the Philosopher's Stone saying it's for
their own good just then he notices
something wrong and shoots at the window
it turns out that the Deadly Woman lost
was spying on them all along she slowly
approaches the trio and despite getting
shot multiple times in the chest does
not stop at last she pins everyone to
the wall using her extended Claws and
then fatally stabs Marco whoops thought
he was wearing plot armor like you guys
once she leaves Marco using his last
breaths tells Edward that the truth
about the Stone's Origins can be found
in laboratory five this is apparently a
secret building that is being used by
the military Edward tries to find out
more about it but sadly Marco passes
away after the incident Edward rushes
back to Tucker's Mansion only to find
that he's created a unique creature that
looks like a blend of a human and a dog
Tucker then reveals that he actually
sacrificed his
and pet dog for the sake of his
experiment furthermore the previous
creature was made from his wife's body
parts hearing this Edward gets enraged
and starts beating Tucker up he almost
kills the mad scientist but fortunately
Alphonse arrives in the neck of time and
stops him after Tucker is apprehended
Edward starts going through several
books in hopes of finding out about
laboratory five however even after weeks
of research he doesn't get a single clue
but one evening as he is still in the
library the military General arrives
there and reveals that laboratory five
is actually the nickname given to the
military Cannery that is no longer
operational hearing this Edward
immediately summons his team and rushes
there meanwhile one of the senior
captains of the military does additional
research on Lab 5 and finds out that it
is actually a large transmutation circle
apparently something is being created
there he tries to inform his superiors
about it but unfortunately lust stops
him from doing so somehow the captain
rushes out of the house and enters a pay
phone to call his gen General but Envy
takes up the form of Colonel Mustang and
kills him the plan is to frame the
colonel and put him behind bars for a
long time unfortunately the plan works
as a few bystanders witnessed the
incident and immediately report it to
the authorities elsewhere the mad
scientist Tucker also escapes from
captivity in the next scene Edward and
his friends are apprehended by the
military on grounds of being associated
with the murderer Mustang they are then
locked inside a room but Edward using
his quick thinking quickly frees the
group and helps them Escape following
this they steal a vehicle and arrive at
laboratory 5 premises where Colonel
Mustang is in a standoff with another
Lieutenant to everyone's surprise he
snaps his fingers and delights the
lieutenant on fire just as it seems that
Colonel Mustang has gone insane the
burning Lieutenant suddenly transforms
herself it turns out it was Envy in
Disguise soon the rest of the bad guys
arrive and the lost stabs Colonel
Mustang in the abdomen injuring him
severely then she flees the scene with
Edward following her closely soon after
Edward arrives at an abandoned room
where a large transmutation circle is
drawn before he can even make sense of
the situation the mad scientist Tucker
shows up he brings out a philosopher's
stone from his pocket and reveals that
these things are actually mass-produced
inside his facility in fact it is the
military that is carrying out the
operation Tucker then reveals that in
order to bring back someone from the
dead a sacrifice is compulsory so the
high-ranking military members were
bringing back their loved ones at the
expense of prisoners hearing this Edward
is taken aback and disgusted but before
he can inquire more lust arrives in the
room and kills Tucker for revealing too
much information here we get to know
that lust is a homunculus a rare but
powerful breed that is artificially
created using Alchemy kinda like moist
critical just then the general who is
The Mastermind behind all of this also
arrives he explained that he did all of
this to create an army of supernatural
beings and that lust is one of his best
warriors he then turns on the power
inside the room revealing thousands of
lifeless creatures inside their pods
after this the general injects the
Philosopher's Stone into a large tank
cylinder and when the solution enters
the creature's body they start coming to
Life One By One The General is excited
to see his babies finally take their
first steps and goes to greet them but
to his dismay they immediately Corner
him and start tearing him up at the same
time the colonel Alphonse Winery and the
other generals also arrive at the room
and team up with Edward to take down the
monsters at first they are easily
outnumbered and it appears as if they
are going to be killed but then Colonel
Mustang figures out that in order to
finish off the creatures they have to
strike their heads using this technique
the group eventually starts making some
kills however the creatures just keep on
coming so Edward and his team are forced
at side there the battle continues as
lust and her goons also show up Colonel
Mustang who is still reeling from the
earlier injury somehow manages to
conjure up all of his strength and
unleash a deadly flame which burns envy
and eventually kills him after this the
colonel turns his attention to lost but
all of his attacks are futile she keeps
regenerating her body even after being
critically impaled through the chest as
Edward and the colonel look on an
astonishment thus reveals that she has a
philosopher's stone embedded within her
chest this is why she has Incredible
strength and healing abilities
unfortunately for her she reveals the
exact thing that she shouldn't have
Edward Alphonse and the colonel gang up
on her and unleash several attacks and
when she is distracted the colonel rips
at the Stone from her chest killing her
instantly meanwhile galatney watches all
this go down from a distance realizing
that his comrades have been killed he
swallows his pride and sneaks out of the
place quietly unwilling to risk his own
life after the battle is finally won
Colonel Mustang hands over the
Philosopher's Stone to Edward saying he
can use it to bring his brother back the
latter obliges and starts his Alchemy
and the next second he is brought next
to the gate of Truth his brother alfons
is also there in his true human form now
all Edward has to do is hand over the
stone to the deity in exchange for his
brother however at the last moment he
backs out Edward no longer wants to use
the evil stone for personal benefit as
he has now seen how it can destroy lives
in the final scene Edward returns back
to reality and apologizes to his brother
for not bringing his body back to his
surprise Alphonse immediately forgives
him saying he doesn't want to use
alchemy either that's okay brother I
didn't miss my dick anyway he reasons
that the Forbidden technique put them in
this state in the first place and it's
best to refrain from the stone forever
the movie ends as the two brothers winry
and the colonel stare at the sun which
is stupid delighted that they have
rescued Earth subscribe for more videos
like this turn on notifications and
leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching